veamos si podemos sacar un poco de
provecho al teorema de la divergencia
así que tenemos esta región r un sólido
simple donde aquí nuestra variable x se
mueve entre menos uno y uno acepta la
podemos ver
digamos acotada por abajo por cero y por
arriba por la parábola 1 - x cuadrada ok
ahora ya también la podemos pensar que
está acotada por cero y la el plano
2 - z éste es igual a 2 - eta es un
plano también tenemos este campo
vectorial de aquí que se ve muy loco
tiene exponenciales tangentes logaritmos
naturales en fin así que nos piden de
este campo vectorial calcular el flujo a
través de esta superficie la la frontera
de esta región
nos piden calcular el flujo y las
integrales de superficie pueden ser muy
engorrosas muy muy complicadas
especialmente en este caso que tenemos
un campo vectorial tan complicado pero
ya podrás pensar que hay una forma de
simplificarlo y una de ella
es usando el teorema de la divergencia
que nos dice el teorema de la
divergencia que este flujo de aquí
debería ser igual a la integral triple
es decir la integral sobre nuestra
región r nuestro sólido r de quien de la
divergencia del campo vectorial de la
divergencia del campo vectorial por una
diferencial de volumen es decir por un
por la multiplicación de de x de jay de
z donde eso esencialmente es un
infinitésimo de área estamos entonces
vamos a vamos a calcular esto vamos a
empezar a utilizar la divergencia y
quien es la divergencia de cualquier
campo vectorial la divergencia de un
campo vectorial no es otra cosa más que
la derivada parcial de la primera
entrada respecto de x mas la derivada de
la segunda entrada
respecto de ye más la derivada de la
tercera entrada respecto de z entonces
si derivamos esta primera con respecto a
x tenemos la derivada de un medio de x
cuadradas simplemente es x porque la
derivada de x cuadrada es 2x por un
medio simplemente es x
este término no depende de x así que al
derivar lo respecto de x se hace
0 ahora de la segunda entrada derivamos
respecto de y la derivada de esto
respecto de ye simplemente es x verdad
esto no depende de ella por lo tanto al
derivar los se cancela y finalmente si
derivamos esta parte respecto de z nos
queda 0 nos queda 0 porque esto depende
de xy de iu y no de zeta así que en la
divergencia nos quedó simplemente x mas
x x mas x perdón que es 2x y esto es lo
que vamos a integrar ahora bien en la
pregunta es cómo vamos a hacer el orden
de integración porque llegue a digamos
se mueve entre 0 y 2 - zeta ceta se
mueve entre entre 0 y 1 - x cuadrada y x
se mueve entre 1 y menos 1 entonces esto
nos va a dar una muy buena idea de cómo
ir integrando fíjense podemos pensar
entonces que que se mueve entre 0
2 - z
2 - z entonces al integrar primero
respecto de iu nos va a dar una función
que depende de z verdad ahora zeta ceta
se mueve entre 0 dijimos que se mueve
entre 0 y 1 - x cuadrada entonces al
integrar después respecto de z nos va a
quedar una función que depende de x y
finalmente x sabemos que se mueve entre
menos uno y uno por lo tanto este es un
buen orden para integrar este es uno muy
bueno como vamos a integrar pues
simplemente este 2x vamos a esta es la
divergencia entonces integramos
en este orden vamos a tener esta
integral respecto de y respecto de iu y
va desde cero hasta dos menos zeta luego
vamos a integrar respecto de vamos a
integrar respecto de z que se mueve
entre 0 y 1 - x cuadrada y finalmente
vamos a integrar respecto de x desde
menos 1 a 1
aquí va de equis y esta es la integral
final que hay que calcular entonces
vamos a calcular primero esta integral
roja esta parte de aquí esta parte de
aquí es muy sencilla verdad porque si
estamos integrando respecto de iu y todo
esto no depende de ella entonces una
primitiva de eso simplemente va a ser va
a ser 2x que es constante por la
integral de eso que es por una primitiva
de 1 que es que y todo esto vamos a
evaluarlo de 0 a 2 - z muy bien cuando
evaluemos esto que es lo que nos va a
quedar lo que nos va a quedar es de gm
de este lado
va a ser 2x bueno si nos damos cuenta
esto cuando lo evaluamos en 0 se hace 0
entonces sólo nos interesa evaluarlo en
el límite superior entonces vamos a
tener 2x que multiplica a que cuando lo
evaluamos en 2 - z entonces simplemente
va a ser que multiplicados menos zeta y
ahora vamos a tener que seguir con los
órdenes de integración como los teníamos
planeados
primero respecto de z de 0 a 1 - x
cuadrada y luego respecto a x de menos 1
a 1 ok vamos ahora a resolver la
integral morada esta integral de aquí
muy bien entonces realmente 2x es una
constante cuando estamos integrando
respecto de z así que podría salir de la
integral
entonces si saliera de la integral aquí
tendríamos 2x por la integral de 0 a 1 -
x cuadrada de 2 - z quien es la integral
de 2 respecto de z déjenme déjenme
ponerlo con rojo tendríamos aquí que
multiplicar
12 está esa es la integral de 2 respecto
de z menos aquí o menos la integral de
zeta respecto de z es ce está cuadrada
sobre 2 y esto ahora lo evaluamos de
déjame ponerlo igual con morado de 0 a 1
- x cuadrada muy bien entonces vamos a
tener que evaluar eso vamos a evaluar
eso vamos a hacer esto un poquito más
abajo entonces esto simplemente va a ser
vamos haciéndolo por pasos 2 x que
multiplica déjenme voy a ponerlo con el
morado que multiplica a bueno si nos
damos cuenta esto cuando lo evaluamos en
0 nuevamente se cancela entonces sólo
nos va a importar evaluarlo en el límite
superior entonces cuando evaluamos esto
en
1 - x cuadrada vamos a tener 2 que
multiplica a 1
- x cuadrada o dejen ya de una vez hacer
la distribución dos por uno es dos menos
dos por equis cuadrada es 2x cuadrada
ese es el primer sumando y ahora hay que
restar un medio un medio de zeta
cuadrada pero evaluado en 1 - x cuadrada
entonces 1 - x cuadrada al cuadrado es
un binomio al cuadrado y nos quedara 11
menos 2x cuadrada más x a la cuarta y
eso es simplemente elevar 1 - x cuadrado
al cuadrado muy bien vamos a ir
simplificando un poco más esta expresión
para que podamos resolver la última
integral y tendremos 2x que multiplica
2 - 2x cuadrada menos y aquí sería un
medio por 1 es un medio menos un medio
por menos 2 x cuadrada en los signos se
cancelan y el 2 por un medio se cancela
también así que nos queda simplemente
más
x cuadrada y finalmente tenemos menos un
medio por x a la cuarta es menos un
medio x a la cuarta muy bien y todavía
podemos simplificar un poco más porque
vamos a tener
2 x 2 x que va a multiplicar a quien el
2 este 2 se puede simplificar o se puede
sumar con este menos un medio
estos son 4 medios menos un medio nos
quedaría aquí tres medios tres medios y
ahora tenemos menos 2x cuadrada con esta
x cuadrada es decir estos dos términos
entonces tendremos menos 2x cuadrada más
una x cuadrada nos queda menos x
cuadrada y finalmente nos queda sumar o
más bien restar un medio de x a la
cuarta entonces
ya vamos a ir concluyendo porque si
utilizamos la propiedad distributiva de
éste de esta de esta multiplicación
tendremos 2x por tres medios los dos se
cancelan y nos queda 3 x 3 x aquí nos
quedaría menos 2 x x x cuadradas serían
2 x al cubo 2 x al cubo y aquí sería 2 x
x menos un medio de x a la cuarta nos
queda menos 2 por un medio se cancelan y
nos queda
x x x cuarta es x a la 5 y esto es lo
que vamos a tener que integrar ahora
respecto de x es decir vamos a tener que
integrar 3 x menos 2 x al cubo menos x a
las 5 todo esto lo vamos a integrar lo
vamos a integrar de menos 1 a 1 respecto
a x muy bien entonces que es lo que nos
queda vamos a tener la integral de 3x
respecto de x es 3 x entre 2 x cuadrada
perdón 3 x cuadrada entre 2 ahora menos
la integral de x al cubo es x a la
cuarta entre 4 pero como tenemos aquí un
2 nos va a quedar un medio de x a la
cuarta ok ya y finalmente la integral de
x a la 5 bueno aquí sería un menos la
integral de x a la 5 es x a las 6 sobre
6 y todo esto lo vamos a tener que
evaluar finalmente de menos 1
qué es lo que obtenemos aquí bueno
cuando evaluamos en uno simplemente nos
queda tres medios menos un medio menos
un sexto ya esto hay que restarle cuando
evaluamos en menos hay que aquí me falta
poner menos uno ok pero en menos uno
fíjense que en el primero nos queda tres
medios menos un medio y menos un sexto
verdad porque menos uno ha elevado a
cualquier potencia par simplemente es
como si sustituto como si fuera con uno
y si nos damos cuenta entonces todos
estos se cancelan este menos un medio se
cancela con este menos un medio porque
los están los estamos restando y lo
mismo pasa con el menos un sexto
entonces qué fue lo que obtuvimos al
final 0 0 es lo que obtuvimos de esta
integral lo cual fue bastante
conveniente y muy bonito porque entonces
esta integral triple que por el teorema
de la divergencia es el flujo del campo
vectorial a través de esta superficie
igual a cero